boris johnson getting on with the job in
kigali hand in hand with his wife carrie
this a day where he needs all the
support he can get
with his commonwealth family on the
world stage in rwanda
back home it was all moving in the wrong
direction
the pm surrounded by commonwealth
leaders
[Music]
and despite brief moments of levity the
show very different at home crushing
by-election defeats and a cabinet
resignation his own leadership in
trouble again we've had some some tough
by-election results and
they've been i think
a reflection of
a lot of things but we've got to
recognize that uh voters are going
through a tough time at the moment and i
think that as a government
i've got to listen to what people are
saying i want to say a big thank you to
oliver dowden who's who's just resigned
he's been an excellent party chairman
and a party chairman who had clearly had
enough telling the prime minister in his
resignation letter he shares supporters
distress and disappointment over recent
events he wrote the pm to say we cannot
carry on with business as usual somebody
must take responsibility and i've
concluded that in these circumstances it
would not be right for me to remain in
office
facing question after question as to
whether boris johnson himself should
remain in office the prime minister
defiant
you don't seem to acknowledge
that you could be part of the problem
you and your conduct could be part of
the problem uh with voters why won't you
acknowledge that i mean you're safe
you've won the confidence vote can you
not just acknowledge that i'm genuinely
genuinely don't think uh the way forward
in british politics is uh to focus on
issues of uh personalities whether they
are mine or others
but also offering a little candor
beth people will you know will continue
to to beat me up uh and and say this all
that about you know
to attack me that's fine that's quite
right that is the job of politicians
in the end uh voters journalists they
have no one else
to make their complaints to i have to i
have to take that but i also have to get
on uh with the job of delivering for the
for the people of this country and
that's what i was elected uh to do
but what's worrying mps is that these
by-election results perhaps show that
the public no longer trust him to
deliver or want him to lead of course
that must be bruising he's had three
body blows today two by-election losses
and the resignation of a cabinet
minister but the killer question is this
does his cabinet and parliamentary party
have the means or appetite to oust him
and for now the answer seems to be not
yet
for now a smile and a bow to royalty
this is a prime minister determined to
wave away party troubles and continue
his reign beth rigby sky news kagali in
rwanda